this is tamar hussein reading for
reviewer richard wakeling at the time of
publishing we need to play a little more
multiplayer so we'll finalize this
review and the score once we've been
able to do that at launch
if 2018's monster hunter world was all
about unearthing a new continent as an
intrepid frontiersman
then rise is a triumphant return to the
old world with valuable lessons learned
rise is the first game in the series
built from the ground up for
switch as such ryze closely follows in
the footsteps of world
while reneging on some of its changes
and introducing plenty of new impactful
ideas that excellently shift the focus
towards the series's heart pumping
action
the core monster hunter gameplay loop
has remained relatively unchanged as you
hunt down gargantuan monsters
harvest their materials to craft new
weapons and armor and tackle
increasingly tougher foes
rise reverts back to the old ways of
splitting village and hub quests
village quests can only be played alone
while hub quests can still be tackled
solo
but are designed with multiple players
in mind this isn't the most welcome
setup for newcomers since it isn't
immediately clear which quests progress
the story
nor is there any indication of whether
or not you should be alternating between
both paths
the impact this structure has on the
game isn't as substantial as it
initially seems though
hunting the same monsters multiple times
has always been a big part of monster
hunter's dna so repeating the same
missions as both a village and hub quest
is something you would typically seek
out anyway
that's not to say rise isn't
approachable in other areas either
a renewed focus on fast-paced action
strikes an impressive balance between
being welcoming for newcomers
and satisfying for battle-hardened
veterans when entering a location for
example
your trusty pet kahoot will mark all of
the nearby monsters on your map
you won't immediately know the identity
of each one until you've actually
discovered them
but this cuts down on the time it takes
to seek out your foe
and gets you into the heart of the
action much faster it's an ideal fit for
the switch's handheld mode allowing you
to jump in and out of the most thrilling
moments without having to engage in the
long-winded slog to find and follow a
monster's tracks
exploration is still a key part of the
experience even if you know the exact
location of your prey
there are plenty of shortcuts and hidden
paths to uncover within each location
and the addition of local wildlife known
as endemic life
encourages you to seek out every nook
and cranny in order to gain the
temporary buffs to damage output stamina
regeneration and so on that they offer
if you're not interested in boosting
specific stats to get a leg up in battle
you can always ignore the endemic life
and tailor the challenge to your liking
rise offers a degree of flexibility in
the way you're able to tackle each
monster that goes beyond your choice of
weapon
and armor the verticality afforded by
the new wire bug mechanic allows you to
zip through the air by utilizing wire
dashing
from here you can chain moves together
mixing in wall runs with additional wire
dashes to reach previously unattainable
heights and traverse the environment at
a rapid pace
the finesse it requires takes some
getting used to and you still need to be
shrewd with the wire bugs forgiving
cooldown to be successful but it's an
incredibly fun tool to use once you're
comfortable with its demands
the wire bug also plays an important
role in combat as each of ryze's 14
signature weapons has its own silk bind
attack
these unique moves are relatively easy
to pull off and range from a timing
based counter with the long sword to an
uppercut leading to an explosive
downward strike with the switch axe
each silk bind attack can be linked into
different combos opening up your
repertoire of potential techniques
and the wire bug expands on this even
further with its defensive maneuvers
the evasive wire fall move for instance
gives you the opportunity to get back on
your feet and avoid a monster's
follow-up attack
after being knocked down or pushed back
while the wire dash extends the reach of
your dodge from when you need to quickly
evade a rampaging beast
each of ryze's weapon types have
remarkable depth in keeping with the
series traditions
mastering a particular weapon is just as
rewarding as before and there's also an
element of customization available this
time around too
the aptly named switch skills allow you
to swap out certain regular and silk
bind attacks to make a weapon that's
reflective of your playstyle
and preferences an improved training
area and the reduction in the amount of
materials necessary to upgrade a new
weapon
also makes this aspect of the game more
approachable for newcomers who need to
experiment in order to find a weapon
type that suits them
stamina and weapon sharpness have also
been streamlined thanks to the addition
of palamutes
these new dog-like bodies will help you
out in combat and can be decked out with
weapons that add to ryze's combat depth
and they also act as mounts for you to
ride anytime you want
stamina isn't consumed when you're
riding on the back of your trusted
palamute and you can even sharpen your
weapon while traversing to give you
something productive to do during travel
thus alleviating some of the more
time-consuming aspects of monster hunter
good job buddy
[Music]
there is a basic story that sets all of
this up by casting you as kamura
village's soul hunter
but the narrative is little more than a
paper-thin vehicle for introducing
ryze's new mechanics
and game modes chief amongst the latter
is the rampage
a special mission type that requires you
to defend a stronghold
from waves of ferocious monsters the
rampage is inspired by japanese folklore
and the hyaki yagyo
night parade of 100 demons idiom in
particular
this sees an uncontrollable horde of
yokai marked into our world and in
gameplay terms the rampage is similar to
a tower defense game
tasking you with placing various hunting
installations around each stronghold
in order to repel the frenzied invaders
some of these installations are
automatic and manned by npc
companions while others can be manually
controlled
rampage quests offer a respite from the
usual monster hunter formula delivering
histrionic thrills as you find yourself
bombarded by multiple monsters at once
there's some satisfying depth to it as
well with progression rewarding you with
more powerful installations
and upgraded weapons completing a
rampage quest will reward you with the
usual assortment of monster parts
with which to craft weapons and armor
but you're also incentivized to finish
them in order to unlock defender tickets
these can be spent on numerous rampage
skills that permanently boost specific
weapon stats such as attack
affinity and defense part of what makes
the rampage so exciting is the addition
of wyvern riding to your offensive
arsenal
monster riding was first introduced in
monster hunter 4 but it's had a
significant shake up in rise by
performing a series of silk bind and
aerial attacks a monster will enter a
mountable state that allows you to hop
on their back and go for a ride
you can launch your helpless prey into
walls to deal damage and put them in a
down state that leaves them vulnerable
for a time
or you can use them as a massive
battering ram to attack
other monsters this is a tad cumbersome
due to some stiff controls but being
able to ravage the monster you're
hunting with another beast is a singular
treat that adds a tinge of kaiju-esque
action to the proceedings
not to mention the strategic
considerations it introduces to each
hunt
the monsters themselves consist of fan
favorites such as wrathion
diablos and pukipiki along with plenty
of new monsters and a few surprises
much like the rampage each of the new
beasts are inspired by yokai and other
legendary creatures from japanese
folklore
going toe to toe with these intimidating
beasts is an unmistakable core of
monster hunter experiences and rai still
feels like a distinctly monster hunter a
game
even if it's more of a fully fledged
action title than any other entry in the
series
this renewed focus doesn't diminish its
layered rpg mechanics
nor does it dumb down on any single
aspect of the hunt
the moment-to-moment combat is as
impeccable as it's ever been
and puts ryze on a pedestal as one of
the feathers in the nintendo switch's
cap
how do you like that